[Musique]
par contre dans le domaine nous allons
aborder maintenant toutes les fantaisies
sont permises dans le domaine des
variétés et avec une image on peut faire
des milliers d'image on peut décortiquer
une image on peut faire dire aux gens et
aux choses au contraire de ce qu'ils
pensent
ça c'est le domaine des magiciens des
variétés et en tête de tout cela il ya
un gars en temps je n'ai pas besoin de
faire l'éloge est dans le nom viennent
tout de suite à votre pensée si jean
christophe averty que nous allons
retrouver maintenant
tcherkessof la télévision française ses
débuts quand nous l'avons connu et était
très libre dans le temps et dans
l'esprit puis le ton s'est fait un peu
plus grave et l'esprit s'est fait un peu
moins légers heureusement vous avez fait
votre apparition en ce moment là vous
avez libéré la télévision de la pire des
oppressions l'oppression de la forme et
l'oppression de l'image et toutes les
voler en éclats les têtes sont parties
d'un côté les jambes sont partis de
l'autre côté et enfin grâce à vous on a
inventé ce mouvement qui déplace les
lignes détesté par le poète mais très
apprécié par les téléspectateurs
non je pense que le trucage électronique
est une manière de poétiser la
télévision dit trop souvent et terre à
terre et se contente de filmer ce
qu'elle voit je pense que la télévision
l'état publiciaires elle constate que de
telle heure à telle heure à telle ou
telle personne sont passés devant telle
et telle caméra et puis c'est tout on se
contente de peu je pense à la télévision
une des voix impressionnante évidence
est de faire rêver et le rêve se fait
avec des images la vita c'est morrow
monotone et assez sinistre assez morose
alors les images que je fabrique sont
des images jamais vues
du moins par mois je pense qu'on ait pas
de dérouter en prison plus si bien que
je ne comprends pas les gens qui
n'aiment pas mes émissions il devrait
même s'il ne se leurrent plaît pas être
content de votre chose de différent donc
voir les assassinats des soeurs de cocu
des meurtres
accident un bébé qui passe dans une
moulinette et plus drôle que n'importe
quel président en
get away je suis bien là je m'en suis
bien sorti janadi a sorti et je pense
que maintenant pour éviter de plus nous
embarquer dans une série sciences qui
nous amènerait très loin à la porte
je pense qu'il est bon de laisser à max
devrait nation stabilité de montrer
prenne son voile pour vous madame yvonne
prendre de vraies si j'ose dire comment
l'en sentir grâce aux trucages qu'ils
expliquent cela nos téléspectateurs le
trucage consiste à faire un montage
analogue à la au montage photographique
en prenant un signal qui va permettre de
découper comme un important pièce le
signal l'image fournie par la caméra et
dans un décor
l'image fournie par la caméra reprend sa
place dans le trou colonna ainsi
constitué et on met autour un décor qui
peut changer
qui peut être bien d'autres images
toutes les images dont nous disposons en
particulier nous pouvons remettre le
haut personnage sur nous mêmes sur
toutes les images que nous fournit le
plateau à ce moment là et à l'intérieur
des personnages on peut aussi
ap la place des personnages mettre ces
images dont nous disposons le trucage
électronique ne consiste pas simplement
à faire que des incrustations le
générateur des faits nous livre un
certain nombre de volets et des
médaillons en particulier ce rectangle
de largeur de hauteur variable et
d'emplacements réglable messieurs
georges de caunes va vous demander dans
quelques instants de jouer avec ce
médaillon mais si ça doit faire une
démonstration c'est une scène classique
un français moyen rentrant chez lui
trouve sa bouteille de vin rouge
ordinaires ne pense pas à mal sans vous
imaginez qu'une caméra télévision suisse
et mouvements serre
se remplit un verre de vin rouge mais il
montre l'étiquette par la même occasion
sans le vouloir il ya cependant toujours
parmi les téléspectateurs quelques
personnages un peu pointilleux
quelquefois un sénateur homme charmant
par nature mais toujours un peu
dirigeants et qui aurait tendance à voir
des arrière pensées oui il y en a pas
qui se dit tiens monsieur macha montre
la marque de talent va qui nous vient
d'une série redevance de france le vin
comment ce n'est pas relaté donc pas
d'arrière pensée pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de souci quelconque monsieur vous avez
vous servir et nous à la régie de
l'enfer en sorte que personne ne puisse
dire quoi que ce soit sur le geste banal
vous accomplissez servez-vous de vin
rouge et buvait tranquillement resservez
vous vous en prie monsieur vu son cachet
d'étiquettes mes parents à cacher rien
nous ferons le nécessaire
ils nous montreront ainsi qu'en france
ni le vin ni nos émissions sont coupés
de lamentations